hello my name is caleb denby and welcome
back
to game review today we're going to be
taking a look
at this game between magnus carlson and
anish geary
in this one we did see magnus playing
the move 1d4 again
we see knight f6 c4 e6
and then in this chessboard masters
final against niche
we did see him play knight c3 and go for
a very interesting a3 nimzo
in this game however he's back to the
usual with knight f3
this is what top grand masters are
usually playing against this move order
from black
to avoid the nimzo indian altogether
with knight c3 and bishop b4
knight f3 forces black to make one more
move and now after d5
we do see the move knight c3 now black
less often
commits to the smooth bishop b4 after
the move d5 has been played
because it limits his options pretty
drastically by already having this pawn
out here on d5
uh anish goes for the
uh or semitash with the move c5
the trash of course is just doing this
all directly move one two three
with the move knight f6 included it is
the semitorach
and with this pawn structure we do see
black taking a very combative approach
to the center
from the get-go here none of this
waiting around in the qgd
waiting for the right moment to play c5
or take on c4
black is saying i am putting the maximum
pressure on the center as quickly as
possible and in this line we do see
black going for
a line that starts to look pretty
similar to the grunfeld if you are
familiar
so we see the move c takes d5 and now
the move e takes d5
isn't going to be the most comfortable
for black you end up
in some iqp positions with this isilani
here on d5
generally at some point these two pawns
get traded and white can play for
pressure against this guy
or after move like v6 pressure against
the hanging pawn center
as well so after cd5 we do see the move
knight takes d5
this is by far uh much much more common
and now the move e4 takes control of the
center and this is what i mean by it
looks a little bit similar to the
grunfeld
we have knight takes c3 b takes c3 and
we have this sort of grunfeld structure
there is a very key difference here
compared to the grunfeld
uh well actually a couple key
differences one being the fact
that black has already committed to the
move e6 and already has the move c5 in
means that his play
is actually coming a little bit faster
perhaps compared to when
g6 and bishop g7 are on the board now of
course
g6 and bishop g7 on the board also
changes things pretty dramatically
now after c takes d4 and c takes d4
black is actually just going to trade
this bishop off rather than go for the
superstar grunfeld bishop
that grunfeld players are very very
familiar with and this is sort of the
key difference here so bishop b4 is a
check
bishop d2 is the response and now bishop
takes d2
queen takes d2 and this is sort of the
starting position for the opening black
generally always castles here now white
does have
various options from this point forward
but with this pawn on e6
the good news for white is that that
means that this bishop has no
access to the g4 square which means this
knight is sitting comfortably on
f3 and there's no need to put a bishop
on e2 or anything on
of this manner so the bishop comes to
the moon more natural square
on c4 putting some pressure on the light
squares
for black now the move i'm actually more
familiar with here is the move knight c6
and the ideas kind of follow with b6 and
knight a5
hitting the bishop then you see bishop
b7 rook c8s
and from what i have usually seen this
rook and the knight work in tandem to
control squares on the c
file and black has a pretty good game in
this game anish geary actually
goes for the other option with knight to
d7
and the idea of this one is to actually
more directly
pressure the pawn on e4 rather than go
for
more normal grunfeld type plans with
knight c6 and a5
anish is putting this knight on f6
challenging e4
and challenging the d5 square as well
these light squares
in the center more directly we have
castles and of course b6
is the natural follow-up rook a
to d1 is the world champion's choice uh
bishop b7
and now rook f to e1 is the other
natural square for the rook
so far so normal we see rook c8 hitting
the bishop
so bishop b3 backing on up we have
rook e eights by anish geary
preparing for the move d5 in which case
the e file
might open up and in fact d5 is a move
that has been played here historically
after ed5 ed5
this is just a perfectly playable
position for black this knight comes out
to a very natural square
on c5 and white does have this past d
pawn
but if black plays well he should be
able to corral this pawn without too
much difficulty
and there are a number of games here by
players such as dave navarra wesley so
sam sevien lenier dominguez but this is
not what we see here today
instead magnus carlson chooses a
slightly less common move
from this position and that move is rook
to e3 and this one is sort of a head
scratcher
anish plays the move knight f6 which is
very very natural
and then generally i always felt like
the idea of rookie three
was to back this rook up with something
like queen e1
guarding this e4 pawn but this is not
what magnus chooses
to do instead he simply plays the move
d5 immediately
and this is raising some some question
marks in my mind
as to why magnus felt the need to put
this rook on e3
but the place becomes a lot more clear
after
the next move here uh ed5 e5
knight e4 and now the point is the e1
square is vacant
for the queen and magnus was not playing
to recapture on d5
going for the past d-pawn scenarios
instead he wants this pawn on e5 and now
with this setup
having this rook on e3 makes a ton of
sense not necessarily
to support the e-pawn from behind
although this is very very relevant
but also to give him these options of
bringing this
this rook over to the king's side and
trying to checkmate
the black king this is what magnus
carlsen is playing for here
not some past d-pawn sort of josh
looking position he wants
d5 takes e5 going for the maximum
so knight e4 queen e1 is played in the
game
we see queen c7 and then magnus
carlson's next move
is very very professional
this is a horribly difficult type of
position
and if i were to achieve a position like
this in one of my own games
i definitely would be taking this pawn
on d5 rook takes d5
and you know kind of cutting my losses
like okay all right got my pawn back
thank goodness i had to trade my bishop
for it i don't care get me out of this
game
but if magnus had done this honestly he
might end up slightly worse
because if you don't make immediate use
of this e5 pawn it is going to turn out
to be
weakness and then it's black with the
better end game with this queen side
majority
for example a move like knight c5 this
knight can come back to e6
and then black is doing very very well
here instead
magnus carlsen says what this pawn yeah
i don't need this pawn and plays
knight d4 uh undefending this pawn
from the only piece that had it covered
now the point of rookie three and queen
e1 is shining through
once again this pawn is not capturable
due to the move f3 when these pieces are
working very very well together
so e5 sort of indirectly defended here
via some tactics
the move a6 comes on the board very
natural by anish wanting to stop
knight b5 to d6 and now we get to
the clown pushing segment of the game
where magnus plays the move h4
and you know say what you will about
this move but
magnus carlsen is playing white in a
rapid game he's trying to checkmate his
opponent with this pawn on e5
he's going all in so why not include the
move
h4 controlling this g5 square
fun stuff fun fun stuff
now anisha's next move is honestly not
my favorite by any stretch
of the word uh the move rook c to d8 was
his choice
and i mean this move is like it's
defending the d-pawn
but if i'm black in this game i'm saying
all right if i don't get checkmated i
have a very good position
all i need to do is not get checkmated
and
the focus in my opinion should really be
on
that and that alone rex cd8 is a move
defending
upon but we don't even care if white
takes this pawn white had his chance to
take this pawn
he did not do it why would he do it now
so i think some defensive moves really
would have served black a little bit
better here
you could consider playing the move h6
the point being you're getting h5
h6 ideas out of the way before they ever
get started
uh other moves would include something
like queen c5 just aiming at some more
central squares
with this queen and a move like b5 as
well
just sort of expanding on the queen side
and getting some counter play
over here rather than just kind of a
tempo losing move like rook c to d8
so now magnus takes this tempo and runs
with it playing the move f3
the natural move to kick this knight
away the knight comes to c5
and now wasting no time at all magnus
says h5
i am here knocking at your door please
let me in 96 was the move by anish giri
uh this is a great square for the night
um taking up a defensive outpost
but now knight f5 by magnus is the
natural
way to go just slowly but surely
uh centering these pieces around the
black king's side
uh d4 now by black is an attempt to
uh get some activity for himself and
this is sort of the justification
for the move uh rook 8 or rook c to d8
but it it still doesn't make that much
sense in my opinion he's trying to push
this d-pawn forward to make it relevant
but there were better ways i think to
defend the king's side
for black rook eats d3 now by magnus
carlson
knight c5 is an attempt to
challenge this rook on d3 we have rick
takes d4
rook takes d4 and rook d4
now anish tries to get pieces off the
board with knight takes b3
and rather than capture this back the
tactics sort of begin here
for magnus throwing in the move queen g3
threatening of course a checkmate so no
time to do anything
on this side of the board g6 and now
magnus does capture this guy back
and now after the move rook d8 it's time
for you guys at home
to start trying to play like the world
champion magnus carlson so white to move
and absolutely crush your opponent here
there are more than one there is more
than one winning move here
but uh you know magnus's i think is is
the most beautiful
so try and find the beauteous way to win
this game
of course the move if you're watching at
home
is the move e6 and this is just
devastating
for a niche this is a discovered attack
on the queen
and not only that it is still
threatening the move
rook takes d8 with checkmate it's also
threatening to rip open the king's side
with something like e takes f7
and this is just game over queen c1 is a
check we see king h2 and now with the
queen removed from the thread of capture
anish goes ahead and takes on d4 but now
i know everybody at home
saw the justification behind this move
e6 the move of course here to win for
white
is the move e7 and now promotion
is quite simply difficult to stop
uh queen c8 was a niche's try but now
queen e5
attacks a rook attacks checkmate
threatens
e8 queen also with checkmate and there's
simply nothing to do here
for black uh rook h4 was the try
and now king g3 is forcing
resignation from anish another beautiful
game
by the world champion here and a really
instructive
attacking game showing how to make use
of this e5 pawn these are positions that
honestly i have struggled with myself
uh it always feels as though the attack
sort of fizzles out and then my e5 pawn
just becomes a weakness
but this game showing how to use it to
attack this knight
not being able to come back to f6 due to
e5 and then the pawn itself becoming a
relevant attacker with the moves e6
and e7 beautiful stuff by magnus carlson
uh thank you so much for joining me on
this episode of game review
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you next time